well a short while ago we showed you  some still images there of her majesty  the queen who has made her first public  appearance since she missed the state  opening of parliament earlier this week  for the first time in decades well we've  now got some moving pictures of her  she's her attending the royal windsor  horse show to watch her animals of  course her favorite pastime take to the  parade ring she was last seen in public  at prince phillips memorial service  back in march but uh there we are see  her being driven  in her range rover there in windsor  where she likes to stay at this time of  year to go and watch  her horses of course equine  interests a deep passion  for her  been concerns about her mobility which  has been why she has missed a few  occasions where we would normally expect  to see her majesty deputized for instead  by of course her son  king in waiting prince charles said  you